This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在 我们这个奇妙的现代世界中，精神坚韧、体能以及培养复原力的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是数字 2 百分号，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。《Look Back at It》播客。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alessian and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。艾伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱西安和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Have you ever been told that you're too sensitive or that you just shouldn't think so much. You're overreacting to something so small. You let the world hurt you, or my all-time favorite, you just take everything so personally. If you are a highly sensitive person,
后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听另一期节目，当然，我们将剖析你二十岁的心理学。你是否曾被告知你太敏感，或者你只是不应该想太多。你对这么小的事情反应过度。你让世界伤害了你，或者我历来最喜欢的，你总是把什么都归咎于自己。如果你是一个高度敏感的人，
these statements are definitely something that you've probably encountered and are most likely sick of hearing. Being a highly sensitive person is so much more than what people think it is. There is such a limited idea that if you're sensitive, you must cry all the time, you ever react, you take things too seriously, that you make it difficult for others. Sensitivity is often synonymous with fragility, being easy to break and feeling like people need to walk on eggshells around you. And these misconceptions treat our sensitivity like a character floor when in fact being a deeply sensitive, gentle feeling person simply means that you have a profound and rich inner emotional
这些话绝对是你可能遇到过并且很可能听腻了的。作为一个高度敏感的人，远比人们想象的要丰富得多。人们有一种非常局限的想法，认为如果你敏感，你就一定经常哭泣，反应过大，把事情看得太严重，给别人制造麻烦。敏感往往是脆弱的同义词，一触即碎，让人觉得别人需要在你周围如履薄冰。而这些误解将我们的敏感视为一个性格缺陷，事实上，作为一个深刻敏感、温柔多情的人，仅仅意味着你拥有一个深刻而丰富的内心世界
life that causes you to see, feel, perceive the world differently and with more color and complexity. Everything is just heightened. The beautiful things about the world are magnified, but so is a lot of the pain and the stress and the sadness. Sometimes that can be overwhelming, but I honestly think it's better to feel a lot than nothing at all. And you know, who decided that being overly sensitive is a bad thing in comparison to being insensitive or completely numb to what you're experiencing. In my mind, there's one of those that is most certainly a better option. So today we are going to discuss what it means to be a highly sensitive person, breaking down some of the myths and the misconceptions that others might have. We're also going to explore what actually
生活，这导致你以不同的方式、带着更多的色彩和复杂性来看待、感受、感知世界。一切都被放大了。世界美好的一面被放大了，但许多痛苦、压力和悲伤也是如此。有时这可能会让人不知所措，但我真心认为，与其什么都感受不到，不如去深深地感受。而且你知道的，谁决定了与不敏感或对经历的一切完全麻木相比，过度敏感是一件坏事？在我看来，其中一个绝对是更好的选择。所以今天我们将讨论作为一个高度敏感的人意味着什么，打破其他人可能有的某些神话和误解。我们还将探讨究竟是什么
makes us sensitive on a genetic level, on a parental level, on a childhood level. On a childhood level the hidden powers and hidden talents of sensitive people when it comes to intelligence, creativity, empathy, how to help people understand you more as a highly sensitive person, and kind of just having an overall conversation around how to make your sensitivity fit into the world, how to make the world make space for you as a sensitive person, and why the world should be doing that, why we need, highly sensitive people like you and I to keep the world spinning, to keep people feeling, to bring empathy and intelligence and a certain emotional vividness to situations that
在基因层面、父母层面、童年层面让我们变得敏感。在童年层面上，敏感的人在智力、创造力、同理心方面隐藏的力量和隐藏的天赋，如何帮助人们更好地理解你作为一个高度敏感的人，以及基本上进行一场关于如何让你的敏感适应世界、如何让世界为你这样一个敏感的人腾出空间，以及为什么世界应该这样做、为什么我们需要像你我这样高度敏感的人来让世界运转、让人类去感受、为其他人可能无法带来这些东西的情境带来同理心、智力和某种情感生动性的整体对话。
other people might not bring those things. So there is so much in this episode that I think might surprise you. So many studies, research papers, fun facts that will hopefully allow you to know your own self even better as someone who is deeply feeling, as someone who is very in tune with the world and everything going on around them. Because I just feel like highly sensitive people deserve to be seen. They deserve to feel acknowledged. They are some of the best people in the world. So I want to make some space for them on this podcast and just talk about it with you guys
所以这一集里有很多内容可能会让你感到惊讶。许多研究、研究论文、趣闻轶事，希望能够让你作为一个内心丰富的人、作为一个与世界以及周围一切都息息相关的人，更好地了解自己。因为我只是觉得高度敏感的人值得被看到。他们值得感到被认可。他们是世界上最好的一些人。所以我希望在这个播客中为他们留出一些空间，并今天和大家一起谈论这个话题。
today. So there is so much on the agenda. I'm going to stop babbling. And without further ado, let's get into the psychology of highly sensitive people and kind of answering that question, am I just? too sensitive. So starting off strong, what are the actual characteristics of a highly sensitive person in comparison to someone who is, I don't know, of regular sensitivity?
所以议程上有很多内容。我要停止唠叨了。废话不多说，让我们进入高度敏感之人的心理学，并解答那个问题：我是不是只是太敏感了？那么首先强势切入，与那些，我不知道，具有普通敏感度的人相比，高度敏感之人的真正特征是什么？
I don't know if it's regular, let's just say average. With everything, what makes someone sensitive, what makes something anything, really varies. It's probably worth noting that there are two different types of sensitivity. there is reactive or environmental sensitivity and personality or internal sensitivity. We all have times when we're just a little bit on edge and we're a little bit fragile, like when we're tired or when our hormones are fluctuating, when our anxiety is biking because of a really stressful period in our lives. These are all incredibly taxing experiences and emotional states that are going to put a strain on our
我不知道这算不算普通，我们姑且称之为平均水平吧。对于任何事情，是什么让一个人敏感，是什么让任何东西成为任何东西，其实都各不相同。可能值得注意的是，有两种不同类型的敏感。一种是反应型或环境型敏感，另一种是人格型或内在型敏感。我们所有人都有过这样的时刻：我们有点紧张，有点脆弱，比如当我们疲惫时，或者当我们的荷尔蒙波动时，或者当我们因为生活中压力很大的时期而导致焦虑达到顶峰时。这些都是极其消耗精力的经历和情绪状态，会对我们的
limited cognitive and mental resources. That is why we are so sensitive during those times in particular, because we genuinely just have less energy in the tank to self-regulate and to process our emotions. So that is environmental or reactive sensitivity. The opposite of this is internal personality, long-standing trait sensitivity. This is the kind of hypersensitivity that is part of who we are, part of our personality. These are the people who we would call highly sensitive persons,
有限的认知和心理资源造成压力。这就是为什么我们在这些特定时期会如此敏感，因为我们内心的能量确实较少，难以进行自我调节和处理情绪。这就是环境敏感或反应敏感。与此相反的是内在人格、长期存在的特质敏感。这就是那种作为我们一部分、作为我们人格一部分的超敏感。这就是我们所说的高度敏感人群，
HSPs, it literally has an acronym. And this was a term that was coined by the psychologist Elaine Aaron in the 90s. And she wrote probably one of the most in-depth books on this titled very appropriately. It's called the highly sensitive person. That is when this experience, this personality trait, this phenomena first got a name. She was the one who began to really observe it, began to draw patterns between people who were all expressing the same reactions and feelings and behaviours. And she labelled those people highly sensitive persons. She also went on to develop a questionnaire that can help people like you and I
HSPs，它甚至有一个缩写。这是心理学家伊莱恩·阿伦在 90 年代创造的一个词。她写了可能是关于这个主题最深入的书籍之一，书名非常贴切。它叫《高度敏感的人》。正是在那时，这种经历、这种人格特质、这种现象第一次拥有了一个名字。她是第一个真正开始观察它的人，开始在所有表现出相同反应、感觉和行为的人之间找出规律。她将这些人贴上了高度敏感人群的标签。她还继续开发了一份问卷，可以帮助像你我这样的人
basically confirm or identify themselves as highly sensitive. people and it's called the highly sensitive person scale. It's free, it's online, it's available to anyone who wants to use it. I'll leave a link in the episode description, but essentially her assessment requires you to simply check some boxes, check the boxes that apply to you based on statements that are said, and at the end, you receive a score. Some of the questions, some of the boxes that you can include things like other people's moods affect me deeply. I am easily overwhelmed by strong sensory input, bright lights, strong smells, weird fabrics. I startle easily.
基本上确认或识别自己为高度敏感人群。人群，它被称为高度敏感量表。它是免费的，在网上，对任何想用它的人开放。我会在剧集简介中留下一个链接，但本质上她的评估要求你只需勾选一些框，根据陈述勾选适用于你的框，最后，你会得到一个分数。有些问题，你可以勾选的一些框包括：别人的情绪对我有深刻的影响。我很容易被强烈的感官输入、耀眼的灯光、强烈的气味、奇怪的面料所淹没。我很容易受到惊吓。
I find it hard and overwhelming to have a lot going on at once. I try hard to avoid making mistakes or forgetting things. I get annoyed when people try to get me to do too many things at once. And then there are also criteria like, I am deeply moved by music, movies and art. I have a rich and complex inner life. When I sense someone is uncomfortable, I tend to know what needs to change in the environment to make them more comfortable,
我发现同时有很多事情发生既困难又让人不知所措。我努力避免犯错或忘事。当别人试图让我同时做太多事情时，我会感到恼火。然后还有这样的标准：我深深地被音乐、电影和艺术所打动。我有着丰富而复杂的内心世界。当我感觉到某人不舒服时，我往往知道环境需要改变什么才能让他们更舒服，
like lighting or needing a pillow, that kind of thing. I think it's really important to highlight those elements of what it means to be a highly sensitive person. Because the misconception is that sensitive people are just too, demanding, take things too personally, too highly strong. The truth is, is that they are actually highly attuned to others' needs, often deeply empathetic as well, deeply feeling, because they exist so closely with their emotions. Everything is on the surface for them. And so sadness is not just sadness, it's deep sorrow. Happiness is not just happiness, it's pure ecstasy.
比如灯光或需要一个枕头之类的东西。我认为强调作为高度敏感之人的这些要素真的很重要。因为误解是敏感的人只是太苛求，把事情看得太个人化，神经质。事实是，他们实际上对别人的需求高度敏锐，通常也具有极高的同理心，情感丰富，因为他们与自己的情绪靠得太近。一切都表现在他们的表面。所以悲伤不仅仅是悲伤，而是深深的哀愁。快乐不仅仅是快乐，而是纯粹的狂喜。
everything exists at the highest level for them. That point about being deeply moved by music, movies, art as well, I find that really, really compelling. I actually saw this video from someone the other day who talked about what it's like to be a highly sensitive person watching the Olympics and how it's just like constant tears because you feel everything that the athletes are feeling even through the screen. and this just really highlights how human it really is to be highly sensitive, how connected we feel to things around us that are beautiful, that move us, that make us feel something.
一切对他们来说都存在于最高水平。关于被音乐、电影、艺术深深打动的这一点，我也觉得非常非常有吸引力。我前几天实际上看到某个人的视频，谈到作为一个高度敏感的人观看奥运会是什么感觉，以及它是如何像不断的眼泪一样，因为即使通过屏幕，你也能感受到运动员感受到的所有一切。而这真正突显了高度敏感是多么符合人性，我们与周围美好的、打动我们的、让我们有所感触的事物之间的连接是多么紧密。
Why is that the case? It's because of an obscure region of the brain known as the VMPFC. Super random, that's all you need to know. The VMPFC, it's the part of the brain that, among other things, adds emotional resonance to. our pure sensory data. So, you know, you see a blanket on a couch. If you didn't have your VMPFC, you'd be like, oh, that's just a random blanket. That's it. You don't really have the same emotional attachment to maybe know that that blanket is, you know, the duna that your grandmother made you for your fifth birthday or, you know, the blanket that you brought to college. That part of
为什么会这样？这是因为大脑中一个鲜为人知的区域，被称为VMPFC。超级随机，这就是你需要知道的一切。VMPFC是大脑的一部分，除其他外，它为我们的纯感官数据增添了情感共振。所以，你知道，你看到沙发上有一条毯子。如果你没有你的VMPFC，你可能会觉得，哦，那只是一条随便的毯子。就是这样。你可能不会有相同的情感依恋，去知道那条毯子是，你知道的，你祖母为你五岁生日制作的羽绒被，或者，你知道的，你带去大学的毯子。大脑的那部分
our brain that sees things applies meaning to them, applies emotion. history to them, that part of our brain is heightened and more active in people who are highly sensitive. It's why you feel something emotional when you see a flower rather than just seeing a flower. This also means that people who are highly sensitive, they experience the world with a greater level of emotional saturation, more color essentially, more vividness. And that can also make us more creative. One study from NYU found in, I think it was 2017, that higher sensitivity to our environment, highly sensitive people, also show higher emotional intelligence, greater emotional sensitivity, and all of that is correlated with higher scores on a creativity test.
我们的大脑能够看到事物并赋予其意义，赋予其情感历史，在大脑高度敏感的人群中，这部分大脑更加活跃。这就是为什么当你看到一朵花时，你会有情感上的感受，而不仅仅是看到一朵花。这也意味着高度敏感的人以更高水平的情感饱和度体验世界，本质上是更多的颜色，更多的生动性。这也可能使我们更有创造力。纽约大学的一项研究发现，我想是在 2017 年，对环境更高的敏感度，高度敏感的人，也表现出更高的情商，更高的情感敏感度，而所有这些都与创造力测试的更高分数相关。
It all kind of comes together, right? Having that real sense of our emotions. Feeling like you can reach out and touch them also means that you can see those emotions and other people. And it also means that you can take those emotions and funnel them into other activities, funnel them into a beautiful form like making art. And I really want that nuance to come through here. This is not a one dimensional experience only defined by feeling overwhelmed, only defined by crying all the time or needing space, needing distance. It is a vivid, emotional and sensory state that brings more color, movement, light, excitement to the world.
这一切都有点联系，对吧？拥有对情感的真实感知。觉得你可以伸手去触摸它们也意味着你可以看到其他人的那些情感。这也意味着你可以把这些情感引导到其他活动中，引导到一种美丽的形式中，比如创作艺术。我真的很想在这里传达出这种细微差别。这不是一种单一维度的体验，仅由不知所措定义，仅由经常哭泣或需要空间、需要距离定义。它是一种生动的、情感的和感官的状态，为世界带来更多的色彩、运动、光线和兴奋。
Sounds like a good thing, but that can also be really, really overwhelming. So highly sensitive people are thought to make up roughly 20% of the general population, which is probably higher than we would expect. obviously with everything it's a bit of a spectrum but again about one and five of us have the kind of brain have the kind of emotional regulation system that notices just a little bit more about the world around us that is just a little bit more impacted by others feelings and also our own an interesting fun fact humans are not the only species that can be classified or defined as highly sensitive Elephants, for example, dolphins, horses, octopuses, they all show varying degrees of emotional and social
听起来是一件好事，但这也会让人感到非常非常不知所措。因此，据认为高度敏感人群约占总人口的 20%，这可能比我们预期的要高。显然，对一切来说这都有点像一个光谱，但同样，我们当中大约五分之一的人拥有这样的大脑，拥有这样的情绪调节系统，能够对周围的世界多注意到一点点，受其他人感受以及我们自己感受的影响也多那么一点点。一个有趣的趣闻是，人类并不是唯一可以被分类或定义为高度敏感的物种。例如，大象、海豚、马、章鱼，它们都在不同程度上表现出情感和社会
sensitivity between them. What's something that those animals all have in common? They're also very, very smart and they're very highly evolved compared to your average reptile or mammal or marsupial, which goes to show that the more connections in our brain, the more neurons, the more intelligent we are, perhaps the more capacity we have to be sensitive creatures. That might explain why, according to recent research by the University of Berkeley, highly sensitive people often have higher IQs, not just EQs. They also are higher in a particular kind of intelligence called sensory intelligence. Basically, we process information more deeply. We find that
敏感性。这些动物有什么共同点？它们也非常非常聪明，与普通的爬行动物、哺乳动物或有袋动物相比，它们进化得非常高度，这表明我们大脑中的连接越多、神经元越多、我们越聪明，也许我们作为敏感生物的能力就越大。这或许可以解释为什么根据伯克利大学最近的研究，高度敏感的人通常拥有更高的智商，不仅仅是情商。他们在一种被称为感官智力的特殊智力上也得分更高。基本上，我们更深入地处理信息。我们发现
We reflect longer on our experiences. We notice kind of subtle details were more affected by them. We draw links between more of our experiences. There was a recent article published by Psychology Today. Actually, it was published just last year. It's funny. The magazine is called Psychology Today, but the article within it published last year. I don't know if that needed clarification, but you got it anyways.
我们对自己的经历进行了更长时间的反思。我们注意到一些微妙的细节，并受其更多影响。我们将更多经历联系起来。最近《今日心理学》发表了一篇文章。事实上，它就在去年发表的。有趣的是，这本杂志叫《今日心理学》，但其中的文章是去年发表的。我不知道这是否需要澄清，但无论如何你都听到了。
And this article linked sensitivity to brilliance. you need to be smart to be as reactive or perceptive of your environment as your sensitivity makes you. You cannot be a dumb, highly sensitive person. That's basically what this article was saying. It's kind of a consolation prize. You know, like, yes, I find it hard to not break down, but at least I might be a genius or I might be a creative prodigy. I would love to hear from you guys. if you are someone who is highly sensitive,
这篇文章将敏感性与才华联系起来。你需要足够聪明，才能对你的环境做出像你的敏感性让你做出的那种反应或感知。你不可能是一个笨拙的高度敏感的人。这基本上就是这篇文章所说的。这有点像安慰奖。你知道，就像，是的，我发现很难不崩溃，但至少我可能是个天才或创造力神童。我很想听听你们的意见。如果你是一个高度敏感的人，
do you do something that requires you to use your more creative side of your brain? Or do you do something that is like someone perceived as like a highly emotional career, like a therapist, like a psychologist, like maybe even a primary school teacher, a kindergarten teacher? I really want to know because I feel like that would be very, very interesting to see. So we spend a little bit of time in kind of what makes a highly sensitive person the criteria, the characteristics, how does it happen? How do we become this way? What actually contributes to this unique way of seeing the world? It's a couple of things. Let's start with the big one. The big one is our
你从事的工作是否需要你使用大脑更有创造力的一侧？或者你从事的工作是别人认为高度情绪化的职业，比如治疗师、心理学家，甚至可能是小学老师、幼儿园老师？我真的很想知道，因为我觉得这会非常非常有趣。所以我们花了一点时间来讨论是什么让一个人成为高度敏感的人，标准、特征，这一切是怎么发生的？我们是如何变成这样的？是什么真正促成了这种看待世界的独特方式？有几个因素。让我们从最大的一个开始。最大的是我们的
innate temperament. Now temperament is kind of exists like one step back from personality. Temperament is the nature that we were born with. You and I most likely have had the same temperament since we were just little kids. If you hear a parent say, you know, oh, my child is just so calm and curious or, yeah, my new baby is so fussy and so short-tempered, they're probably not wrong. That kind of personality that a child has
先天气质。现在气质的存在有点像人格退后一步。气质是我们生来就有的天性。你和我很有可能从小时候起就拥有相同的气质。如果你听到父母说，你知道，哦，我的孩子是如此冷静和好奇，或者，是的，我的新宝宝是如此大惊小怪和暴躁，他们可能并没有错。孩子拥有的这种个性
contributes to our future personality because it's our temperament. And the temperament of highly sensitive people, there's four different types of temperaments, the one that highly sensitive people most often sit in is the melancholic temperament. Melancholic people are more reserved, they're more thoughtful, analytical, but also deeply feeling. Sometimes that can be confused with anxiety. People with a melancholic temperament are also highly empathetic. And we know that
有助于我们未来的个性，因为它是我们的气质。而高度敏感之人的气质，有四种不同类型的气质，高度敏感之人最常处于其中的那种是忧郁质。忧郁质的人更内敛、更深思熟虑、更具分析能力，但也情感深刻。有时这可能会与焦虑混淆。具有忧郁气质的人也高度富有同理心。我们知道
being an empath and being highly sensitive often comes hand in hand, because as someone with high empathy, you are naturally going to feel subtle changes in people and your environment. You pick up on those invisible cues that others may not. You notice when someone is suddenly going quiet and you absorb the feelings and the emotional states of those around you, which is what makes you so reactive to them. Because once you've had that intuition that this is how someone's feeling, it can be difficult not to respond, not to want to fix it, not to want to reduce the discomfort, not just for yourself, but for others as well. This really explains why one of the criteria for being a highly sensitive
作为一个共情者和高度敏感的人往往密不可分，因为作为具有高同理心的人，你自然会感受到人和环境中的微妙变化。你会察觉到其他人可能察觉不到的那些无形线索。你会注意到当某人突然变得安静时，你会吸收周围人的感受和情感状态，这就是为什么你对他们如此具有反应性。因为一旦你有了这种直觉，这就是某人的感受，就很难不做出回应，很难不想去解决它，很难不想减少这种不适，不仅为你自己，也为其他人。这就很好地解释了为什么成为高度敏感人群的标准之一
person is needing more downtime, needing more time to decompress after those big social days, after being around people for so long, because you're probably freaking exhausted if you've spent all those hours literally just absorbing everybody else's feelings, taking on all of that, trying to mediate and manage how other people are coping, as well as how you're coping on the inside, what you're actually feeling. Like, it's incredibly draining, I think, to be that alert, even if it's not something that you're consciously doing. So temperament is one of the first factors that just contributes to you being an innately sensitive person. Another factor at play, though, is of course, genetics.
是需要更多的休息时间，在那些大型社交日子之后、在长时间处于人群之中之后需要更多时间来解压，因为如果你花了所有那些时间字面意思上只是吸收了其他所有人的感受、承担了所有这些、试图调解和管理其他人的应对方式，以及你内心如何应对、你实际在感受什么，你可能会精疲力竭。比如，保持这种警觉令人难以置信地消耗精力，即使这不是你有意识在做的事情。所以气质是促成你成为一个先天敏感之人的首要因素之一。不过，发挥作用的另一个因素当然是基因。
So there is a developmental psychologist at Queen Mary University of London, Dr. Michael Pluis, and he is the one who has done a lot of research into this. He basically is suggested that your genes account for 47% of how sensitive you are, nearly half. How he found this out, he looked at twins, and he looked at. and he looked at twins who, basically he was like, okay, if I get two twins here and one of them is highly sensitive,
伦敦玛丽女王大学的发展心理学家迈克尔·普鲁伊斯博士，他就是在这方面做了大量研究的人。他基本上提出，你的基因占了你敏感程度的 47%，接近一半。他是如何发现这一点的呢，他研究了双胞胎，他研究了。他研究的双胞胎，基本上他是这样的，如果我这里有两个双胞胎，其中一个是高度敏感的，
what are the chances that the other one's going to be highly sensitive as well? And the chance was around 50%. And so that's how he kind of determined that that was the genetic influence behind this trait, behind this experience. The rest is environment. We're going to get to that in a second. But the genetic blueprint that we receive from our parents
另一个人也是高度敏感的几率是多少？几率在 50% 左右。这就是他如何确定这种特质、这种经历背后的基因影响的。其余的是环境。我们一会儿就会讲到。但是我们从父母那里得到的基因蓝图
is basically going to determine so much, about who we become and who we become as a sensitive individual. It's going to determine our threshold for simulation. It's going to really help determine our anxiety levels, our attentional systems, our level of alertness, all of which contribute, I guess you can guess it, to hypersensitivity. There is not just one gene at play here, though. There's not just a single gene, if it's flipped or not,
基本上将决定很多，关于我们成为谁以及我们作为一个敏感个体会成为谁。它将决定我们对刺激的阈值。它将真正有助于决定我们的焦虑水平、我们的注意力系统、我们的警觉水平，所有这些，正如你所能猜到的，都会导致超敏反应。不过，这里起作用的不仅仅是一个基因。不仅仅是单一基因，无论它是被开启还是没有，
if it's switched or not, that's going to determine whether you emerge as a highly sensitive person, there's actually three genes, the sensitivity gene, the dopamine gene, and the emotional vividness gene. So let's start off with the sensitivity gene first. The sensitivity gene is also known as the serotonin gene, and it controls how serotonin is transported in the brain. Serotonin is what helps balance our mood. People who are highly sensitive often have a gene variant that means they have less serotonin available in their brain. Less serotonin. What does that normally mean?
无论它是否被转换，这将决定你是否会成为一个高度敏感的人，实际上有三个基因，敏感基因、多巴胺基因和情感生动性基因。让我们首先从敏感基因开始。敏感基因也被称为血清素基因，它控制血清素在大脑中的传输。血清素有助于平衡我们的情绪。高度敏感的人通常有一种基因变异，这意味着他们大脑中可用的血清素较少。血清素较少。这通常意味着什么？
Less mood stabilization. Less capacity to regulate your emotional response to what's going on around you and within you. The second gene is somewhat similar. It's the dopamine gene. A lot of us see dopamine as simply the happy chemical. It's the chemical that keeps us bright and bubbly. and cheery and to an extent you'd be right. But the reason it makes us so happy is because it makes us feel rewarded by external stimuli.
较少的情绪稳定。调节你对周围发生的事情和内心发生的事情的情绪反应的能力较弱。第二个基因有点类似。它是多巴胺基因。我们许多人认为多巴胺仅仅是快乐的化学物质。它是让我们保持明亮、活泼、
When that gene is mutated or when it varies, it can make it so that we are almost overflowing with dopamine and a bunch of other neurochemicals in response to our environment. Meaning that there's just almost too much. Our brain just can't cope. Everything is a bit unbalanced. And so we don't get the same leveled sense of reward or reinforcement from things that other people do like bright lights, like busy environments, like loud pumping music, like intense smells. It just all feels quite messy in our brains.
欢快，某种程度上你是对的。但它之所以让我们如此快乐，是因为它让我们觉得受到外部刺激的奖励。当这个基因发生突变或变化时，它会使我们在对环境的反应中几乎充满多巴胺和一堆其他神经化学物质。这意味着几乎太多了。我们的大脑根本无法应对。一切都有点失衡。因此，我们无法从其他人做的事情（如明亮的灯光、繁忙的环境、响亮震撼的音乐、强烈气味）中获得与其他人相同水平的奖励或强化感。在我们的脑海中，这一切都让人感觉相当杂乱。
It just feels quite overwhelming because there's just actually too much going on for your brain to really put together. But it also sometimes feels really beautiful. If you've got this dysregulated dopamine system, yes, it does mean that, you know, things feel overwhelming at times, but it's also why we feel so moved by things that others might not. And moved by things that other people don't appreciate, like a beautiful view, like a flower, like a TV commercial. Finally, we have the emotional vividness gene. Goes without saying, but I'll say it anyway, most highly sensitive people are keenly aware that they have stronger emotional emotional. reactions than others.
感觉相当不知所措，因为实际上有太多事情发生，你的大脑无法真正组合在一起。但有时它也感觉真的很美。如果你有这个失调的多巴胺系统，是的，这意味着，你知道，事情有时会让人不知所措，但这也是为什么我们会被其他人可能无法欣赏的事物深深打动。并被其他人不欣赏的事物所打动，比如美丽的风景，比如一朵花，比如电视广告。最后，我们有情感生动性基因。不用说，但我还是会说，大多数高度敏感的人都敏锐地意识到他们比其他人有更强的情感反应。
And they often notice those emotional undercurrents in other people. You pick it all up. You pick up what everybody else is putting down silently, unconsciously, implicitly. If you're highly sensitive, this is not your imagination. You actually have a brighter palette of emotional colors, so to speak, because of a variant in a gene that controls how our body's stress response, perception, and sensory imaging is processed by our brain. So essentially what that means is that when we're looking at our environment,
他们经常注意到其他人身上那些潜在的情感暗流。你把这一切都吸收了。你默默地、无意识地、含蓄地吸收了其他人抛出的所有东西。如果你高度敏感，这不是你的想象。由于控制我们身体的压力反应、感知和感官成像是如何被我们的大脑处理的基因变异，可以说你实际上拥有更明亮的情感色彩调色板。所以本质上这意味着，当我们审视我们的环境时，
the highly sensitive person has more, like we said, emotional colors to deal with. It takes in more information from our environment. It takes in smaller details that overload our brain and can make us feel, again, really, really overwhelmed. So if you're feeling constantly kind of burn, out by the world, constantly like exhausted by it, you kind of have your genetics to blame because there is a 47% chance that they are what contributed to you being a highly sensitive person. But a crucial factor that really elevates all those prior determinants and which we really have
高度敏感的人需要处理更多，正如我们所说，情感色彩。它从我们的环境中吸收更多信息。它吸收更小的细节，使我们的大脑超载，并再次让我们感到非常非常不知所措。因此，如果你经常感到被世界烧毁，经常觉得筋疲力尽，你有点只能怪你的基因，因为有 47% 的概率它们促成了你成为一个高度敏感的人。但一个至关重要的因素，真正提升了所有这些先前的决定因素，而我们真正才
only scratched the surface on is upbringing. Childhood trauma can create high sensitivity through learning. learning what we need to do to survive in those early childhood environments and also by activating our melancholic temperament or our genetic predisposition. That kind of early environment that is heightened and intense and rough that may have conditioned you to be very, very alert and responsive to other people's emotions and also what's going on around you because you had to be. You had to be able to pay attention to navigate that minefield.
刚刚触及皮毛，那就是后天教养。童年创伤可以通过学习创造高敏感性。学习我们需要做什么来在那些早期的童年环境中生存，并通过激活我们的忧郁气质或我们的基因倾向来做到这一点。那种早期环境高亢、强烈而粗糙，可能已经让你变得非常非常警觉和对其他人的情绪做出反应，同时也对周围发生的事情做出反应，因为你必须如此。你必须能够集中注意力来驾驭那个雷区。
You had to know what will upset people, what won't. How can I tell if they're angry? What do I need to look out for? How do I stay on their good side by picking up on clues and small things from them that they are unhappy, that they are angry and getting them back to that more neutral state where I'm not going to be hurt, where I'm not going to get the brunt of things? that hyper alertness and anxiety carries on into adulthood and comes out as hypersensitivity, when really it probably was a protective mechanism, a defense mechanism at some stage.
你必须知道什么会惹恼别人，什么不会。我怎么能看出他们是否生气？我需要注意什么？我如何通过从他们身上捕捉到暗示和小事来保持在他们好的一面，证明他们不高兴，他们很生气，并让他们回到更中立的状态，在那里我不会受到伤害，我不会首当其冲地承受这一切？那种高度警觉和焦虑一直延续到成年，并表现为超敏反应，而在某个阶段，它可能只是一种保护机制、防御机制。
It doesn't, you know, those childhood experiences don't even need to constitute the kind of trauma that I think we're imagining. It can even come down to a lack of parental warmth or inconsistency from your caregivers. warm, supportive, gentle parenting helps children develop healthy emotional regulation. Sounds super, super simple. But if you have a parent who is going to see that you're upset or see that you're angry and sit with you and talk you through it or acknowledge that emotion, you basically are able to find a place to put that feeling.
这并不意味着，你知道，那些童年经历甚至不需要构成我们想象中的那种创伤。它甚至可以归结为缺乏父母的温暖或照顾者的不一致。温暖、支持、温柔的育儿帮助儿童发展健康的感情调节能力。听起来超级超级简单。但如果你有一个父母，他看到你心烦意乱或看到你生气，坐在你身边和你一起度过难关或承认那种情绪，你基本上能够为那种感觉找到一个安放的地方。
You're able to find a way to move it from that very instinctual moment where you're reacting and the emotion is very bright and in your face and kind of taper it down, find a space for it, you know, really think it through and make that emotion more neutral. Essentially what I'm kind of saying is that you have healthy coping strategies because someone showed you how to do it.
你能够找到一种方法，将它从那个非常本能的时刻移开，在这个时刻你正在反应，情绪非常强烈、直面你的脸，然后将其逐渐减弱，为它找到一个空间，你知道，真正深思熟虑并使那种情绪更加中立。本质上我想说的是，你有健康的应对策略，因为有人向你展示了如何做到这一点。
Without those coping strategies, people, children struggle to manage their emotions and not only does that mean that yes, our emotions feel more out of our control, but it also means that, that you're very sensitive to stress, to the stress of not being able to manage your emotions, to criticism over not being able to manage your emotions and unexpected social interactions where you don't really know how to behave. You're not, you're kind of stressed that like,
没有这些应对策略，人们，孩子们挣扎着管理他们的情绪，这不仅意味着是的，我们的情绪感觉更不受我们控制，这也意味着，你对压力非常敏感，对无法管理情绪的压力敏感，对因无法管理情绪而受到的批评敏感，以及对你真的不知道该如何表现的意外社交互动敏感。你有点紧张，比如，
what if I'm suddenly angry or upset or something triggers me? What do I do? Because I just actually don't know how to. So many parents tell their kids to just suck it up or to stop overreacting or to come back when you've calmed down, thinking that it's going to make their kids tougher. But if you are already a sensitive child, how are you going to learn how to process those feelings by yourself when you are just a child? All that is going to do is make your emotions feel even less manageable and you're going to feel even more fearful about talking about it. You're going to feel so isolated and like you just need to stuff it all down. Otherwise, you'll get yelled at.
如果我突然生气或心烦意乱或有什么触发了我怎么办？我该怎么办？因为我其实真的不知道怎么做。很多父母告诉他们的孩子只要挺过去，或者停止过度反应，或者当你平静下来时再回来，认为这会使他们的孩子更坚强。但如果你已经是一个敏感的孩子，当你只是个孩子时，你将如何学会自己处理这些感觉？所有这一切只会让你的情绪感觉更难以掌控，你会对谈论它感到更加恐惧。你会感到如此孤立，觉得你只需要把这一切都压下去。否则，你会挨骂。
Otherwise, you'll get criticized. Otherwise, you'll be told that you're too sensitive. We also talk a lot about attachment style in this podcast, of course. Children who don't receive consistent warmth and affection from their parents will also often develop insecure attachment styles. This can also contribute to hypersensitivity because we become very overly anxious about our relationships and not just our romantic relationships, but the relationships we have, you know, with our friends when we're casually dating with our parents, with our family, because we are hyper alert to, once again, rejection or criticism because we fear abandonment.
否则，你会受到批评。否则，你会被告知你太敏感。当然，我们在本 podcast 中也经常谈论依恋风格。没有从父母那里获得一致温暖和关爱的儿童也经常会发展出不安全依恋风格。这也会导致超敏反应，因为我们对我们的关系变得非常过度焦虑，不仅是我们的恋爱关系，还有我们拥有的关系，你知道，当我们随意约会时的朋友关系，与父母的关系，与家人的关系，因为我们再次对拒绝或批评高度警惕，因为我们害怕被抛弃。
We fear that someone is disappointed or angry with us. And so we become hyper vigilant to any small sign that that is the case. and that is what kind of trains our hypersensitivity. And that hypersensitivity to rejection in particular is something that we haven't really spoken about in this episode. But a lot of people who identify as highly sensitive feel that very intensely. They feel that rejection and sensitivity incredibly intensely when they get even the slightest feeling that someone is pulling away or that a relationship is under threat.
我们害怕某人对我们失望或生气。因此，对于任何出现这种情况的小征兆，我们都会变得高度警惕，而这正是训练我们超敏反应的原因。特别是对拒绝的超敏反应，是我们在这集节目中没有真正谈论过的事情。但许多自认为是高度敏感的人对此有着极其强烈的感受。当他们甚至有一点点感觉某人正在退缩或关系受到威胁时，他们对这种拒绝和敏感性的感受是难以置信地强烈。
That is scary for anyone, but if you're highly sensitive, it's so much all at once. It's so much having to think about someone else's emotions, your emotions, whatever environment you're in, and so it can lead to behaviours that we don't feel so proud of later on. Lashing out, completely shutting down as like our brain's final defence, like line of defence, like let's just shut this down so we don't have to deal with this. pushing someone away even more because at least that's going to take the source of our stress away. Then if you are feeling so on edge, so overwhelmed, sometimes all you want to do is just escape and just not deal with it. And so you push or you run away or you just find a way to avoid.
对任何人来说这都很可怕，但如果你高度敏感，这一切就太同时发生了。有太多关于思考别人情绪、你情绪、你所处任何环境的事情需要考虑，因此它可能导致我们以后感觉不太自豪的行为。大发雷霆，完全关闭，作为我们大脑的最后防御，就像最后一道防线，就像让我们关掉这个，这样我们就不必处理这个了。把某人推得更远，因为至少这会带走我们的压力源。那么，如果你感到如此紧张、如此不知所措，有时你唯一想做的事就是逃跑，干脆不去处理它。所以你推开或者逃跑，或者只是找到一种逃避的方式。
When we finally had the space in the alone time to really work through our perspective and our reaction, you know a lot of highly sensitive people do need that time, sometimes we do feel like the damage is done or that we can't even go back and apologize or confront them again because it's just too much. It's just way too much. And in that way, we also see a cycle of conflict, aversion. Of course, conflict is going to be so hard for you if you're highly sensitive because everything is elevated, magnified, heightened. You're sensing subtle shifts that they don't. You're perceiving their emotions.
当我们终于有了空间和独处时间来真正理清我们的视角和反应时，你知道很多高度敏感的人确实需要那个时间，有时我们确实觉得伤害已经造成了，或者我们甚至不能再回去道歉或再次对抗他们，因为这太过了。这简直太多了。通过这种方式，我们也看到了冲突规避的循环。当然，如果你高度敏感，冲突对你来说将是如此艰难，因为一切都被放大、夸大、拔高了。你正在感知他们没有的微妙变化。你在感知他们的情绪。
You're trying to manage your own reactions. It can feel very overwhelming. Because of that sensory overload, sometimes you can say the wrong things. You just want it to end. You can't always process everything that's coming together at once. It's hard, even when we actually do try our hardest, especially when the people that we're communicating with just don't get it. Like we're not trying to be difficult.
你正试图管理你自己的反应。这会让人感觉非常不知所措。由于感官超载，有时你会说错话。你只是想让它结束。你不能总是处理同时汇聚在一起的一切。这很难，即使在我们真正尽了最大努力的时候，特别是当我们与之交流的人根本不理解时。就像我们不是故意表现得难以相处。
We're not reading too much into what you're saying. saying. We're not trying to get frustrated. We're trying really hard not to cry because we don't want you to dismiss us as just being overly sensitive. But there is so much buzzing around in our brains. We feel this so deeply. The emotion is so intense. What else are you meant to do? If you find yourself in that pattern with a partner, with a parent, with a friend who just doesn't understand, who thinks that maybe you're using tears as like a guilt mechanism or that you just can't stay calm and it's and you know it's because you're choosing not to please send them this episode because i think once people have more information about how your brain is working and operating differently to them
我们没有过度解读你所说的话。我们并不是故意感到沮丧。我们正在非常努力地克制自己不哭，因为我们不希望你把我们打发为只是过度敏感。但我们的脑海里有太多的嗡嗡声。我们对此有着如此深刻的感受。这种情绪是如此强烈。你还能怎么做？如果你发现自己与一个根本不理解你的伴侣、父母或朋友陷入这种模式，他们认为你可能是在把眼泪当作内疚的机制，或者你只是无法保持冷静，而你知道这是因为你选择不去，请把这一集发给他们，因为我认为一旦人们有了更多关于你的大脑如何以不同于他们的方式工作和运转的信息
there is more empathy and understanding and adjustment they also can kind of hopefully lean in and understand the fact that this isn't a choice there is this amazing TED talk called The Gentle Power of Highly Sensitive People, highly recommend that talk, and in it, the speaker talks about how telling a sensitive person to just tone it down, to not let the world hurt them, to be less sensitive,
会有更多的同理心、理解和适应，他们也可能多少会倾向于去理解并明白这不是一种选择。有一个非常棒的TED演讲叫《高度敏感之人的温柔力量》（The Gentle Power of Highly Sensitive People），强烈推荐大家去看。在演讲中，演讲者谈到了告诉一个敏感的人稍微收敛一点、不要让世界伤害他们、变得不那么敏感，
is like telling a person with blue eyes to make their eyes less blue. No matter how many times you tell them, chances are you're still going to see those blue eyes staring back at you. And the same goes for sensitivity. It's not something that you can just switch off. And to be honest, I don't even think that it's something that you should switch off. I'm going to go backwards here for a second because there's one more element explanation for this
就像告诉一个蓝眼睛的人让他们的眼睛没那么蓝一样。不管你告诉他们多少次，你很可能还是会看到那些蓝眼睛在看着你。敏感也是如此。这不是你能说关就关的东西。说实话，我甚至不认为这是你应该关掉的东西。这里我先倒退一小步，因为关于这个还有一个要素解释
that we need to discuss. It would be so short-sighted to not mention neurodivergence. So often, someone is told that they are just too sensitive when it's actually them masking their autism or their ADHD because the pattern of behaviors are really, really similar. And they're often comorbid. so you can have both at once. But what's really frustrating is when people are just seen as too sensitive or too emotional or told that they need to toughen up,
我们需要讨论。如果不提神经多样性，那就太短视了。很多时候，当一个人掩饰自己的自闭症或ADHD时，别人却对他们说他们只是太敏感了，因为这两种行为模式真的、真的很相似。而且它们经常并发。所以你可以同时拥有这两种特质。但真正让人沮丧的是，当人们被视作太敏感或太情绪化，或者被告知他们需要坚强一点时，
when their sensitivity is actually a sign of something bigger and larger. People with ADHD often find it takes less stimulation for them to be overwhelmed. So in that way, they are going to present as highly sensitive. The same goes for people with autism, right? Like sometimes new environments, new situations, even new feelings can just be able to be. feel like a lot or in situations where it's just really hard to tell what people are thinking you're not picking up on those cues it's going to make it seem like you're being really sensitive or reactive actually you just don't really know what's going on and that's totally okay sometimes
而实际上他们的敏感是某种更大问题的征兆。患有ADHD的人通常发现自己需要更少的刺激就会不知所措。所以从这个意义上讲，他们会表现得高度敏感。自闭症患者也是如此，对吧？比如有时新的环境、新的局势，甚至是新的感受，都会让人感觉难以承受；或者在那些很难判断别人在想什么、你没有捕捉到这些线索的情境下，这会让你显得非常敏感或具有反应性，而实际上你只是不太清楚发生了什么，这完全没关系。有时候，
like human emotion is not like an open and closed book whether you have a diagnosable disorder that's comorbid or you are just someone who is highly sensitive I think it's all the same it's still going to be difficult to manage your emotional reactions and you're still going to feel like people have some kind of stigma around high sensitivity. People think that you're weak or that you're fragile or whatever. I'm going to be super honest with you all now. My perspective on this is very anti-shame. Very anti-let's find a cure for all us highly sensitive people. Let's make us normal. I don't want us to suppress our emotions. I don't want us to try and chameleon or try and blend in with the 80% of people who quote unquote have average sensitivity levels because firstly it backfires we feel even more overwhelmed.
人类的情感就像一本合不上的书。无论你是有可诊断的并发障碍，还是你只是一个高度敏感的人，我认为这都是一样的：管理你的情绪反应依然会很困难，而且你仍然会觉得人们对高度敏感抱有一种偏见。人们会觉得你软弱、脆弱，诸如此类。现在我要对大家非常坦诚。我对这件事的观点是坚决反对羞耻感的。坚决反对“让我们为所有高度敏感的人寻找一种治愈方法、让我们变得正常”这种想法。我不想让我们压抑自己的情绪，我不想让我们试图伪装成变色龙，去试图融入那80%所谓的具有平均敏感度水平的人群中，因为首先这会适得其反，我们会感到更加不知所措。
So not only does it not work, it makes us feel worse. And secondly, I just don't see a reason why you should. I really think that sensitivity is kind of a superpower. Being gentle and emotional and attune and in tune with others is quite gorgeous. and quite special to have. You know, this trait isn't going to change. It's a lifelong thing. Hopefully that's not too hard to hear. But I think the earlier we come to terms with that,
所以它不仅不管用，还会让我们感觉更糟。其次，我实在找不到你非要这么做的理由。我真的认为敏感其实是一种超能力。温柔、情绪化、敏感并与他人同频是非常美妙的，也是一种非常特殊的特质。你知道的，这种特质是不会改变的。这是一生相伴的。希望这个事实听起来不会太难接受。但我认为，我们越早接受这一点，
the easier life feels, the more freeing. It's like the weight of needing to dim down is lifted because once we acknowledge, like, this is part of who I am, it's not going away, it's not going to change. It's kind of at that point that you realize how exhausting is going to be to keep, you know, to keep up the facade for the rest of your life. And eventually you realize that maybe you just shouldn't. Maybe it's not worth it.
生活就会感觉越轻松，越自由。就像那种需要收敛光芒的沉重负担被卸下了，因为一旦我们承认，这也就是我的一部分，它不会消失，也不会改变。正是在那个时候你会意识到，为了余生继续维持那种虚伪的面具将是多么令人筋疲力尽的一件事。最终你会意识到，也许你根本不该这样做。也许这不值得。
Maybe life isn't all about trying to make other people feel comfortable with you. And it's about trying to make your life feel comfortable for yourself. So I want to talk about all of that and more how to really make the world fit your sensitivity rather than the other way around after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
也许生活并不全是为了让别人对你感到舒适，而是为了让你的生活对自己而言感到舒适。所以在短暂的休息之后，我想谈谈所有这些以及更多内容——如何真正让世界适应你的敏感，而不是反过来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》（2%）中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧精神、体能和抗逆力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等人对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
来抛弃那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（调侃）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为国会。
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
可卡因。我随时都可以聊当年的可卡因，只是让大家知道而已。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上回听。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking. Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession
我在谈论。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞恩·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了
of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
那个东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在这世上活着的好人很重要？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
你是一个好人，还是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《迎难而上》中就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test won.
打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克特（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is served in Arizona.
这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事还远远没有结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Highly sensitive people are some of my favorites to be around because they make the people around them see the world more beautifully. They are also incredibly gentle and empathetic. They are creative. And they just bring big heart and big love to everything that they do. like nothing is small for them.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。高度敏感的人是我最喜欢相处的人之一，因为他们让周围的人以更美丽的方式看待世界。他们也极其温柔和善解人意。他们很有创造力。他们为所做的一切都倾注了博大的胸怀和浓浓的爱意。对他们来说，似乎没有什么事是小事。
Your highly sensitive friend is probably going to be the one who remembers your birthday. They are probably going to be the one who makes you feel safest, who is going to introduce you to new music, who wants to go on long nature walks with you, who will, you know, point out small things that you didn't notice. They are the ones who are going to make you feel comfortable in their space, who is going to give you so much love in a relationship.
你那个高度敏感的朋友很可能是那个会记住你生日的人。他们很可能是那个让你感到最安全的人，会带你接触新的音乐，想和你一起去进行漫长的大自然散步，会（你知道的）指出那些你没有注意到的微小事物。他们是那些会让你在他们的空间里感到舒适的人，是在恋爱中会给你巨大爱意的人。
I just don't understand why we don't want more of that in the world. Feeling everything so deeply might sometimes feel like a curse, but compared to feeling nothing at all and never being touched by that joy and never feeling deeply human, sometimes I do think it's a privilege. Like, I have met people who just don't care about anything. They don't have any sense of justice. They don't have any sense of beauty or wonder or or excitement. And it's a pretty bland life. That's a very, on top of the fact that, you know, the research and the science will tell you, your IQ, your creative intelligence, your emotional vividness, your sensory intelligence is probably higher
我只是不明白为什么我们不希望世界上多一些这样的人。把一切都感受得如此深刻有时可能像是一个诅咒，但与什么也感受不到、从未被那种快乐触动、从未深刻体验过人性相比，有时我确实认为这是一种特权。就像，我遇到过一些对什么都不在乎的人。他们没有任何正义感。他们对美、对惊奇或对兴奋没有任何感知。那是相当平淡的生活。最重要的是，你知道的，研究和科学会告诉你，你的智商、你的创造力智力、你的情绪生动度、你的感官智力可能都高于
than the average person. I think that keeps us really focused on the strength that comes with being a highly sensitive person, even during the times when we're told that we're too much. Those people who say that, I'm going to be completely honest, they can get over it. They can get over it. Your purpose in life is not to make others comfortable with you. If someone thinks that you are too intense, feels too strongly if they think that you overreact, their opinion is a reflection of the level of empathy that they are prepared to show others. Not a reflection of you and what needs to change in your life. I just don't, like, who made the rules that said that being too sensitive is a bad thing?
普通人。我认为这让我们真正专注于作为一个高度敏感的人所带来的力量，即使在我们被告知我们“想太多/反应过度”的时候也是如此。说那些话的人，老实说，他们可以克服它。他们可以克服它。你在生活中的目的不是让别人对你感到舒适。如果有人觉得你太强烈、感受太强烈，如果他们觉得你反应过度，他们的意见反映的是他们准备向他人展示的同理心水平。而不是反映你以及你生活中需要改变的地方。我只是不明白，究竟是谁定下了“太敏感是一件坏事”这样的规则？
I heard from this really amazing person when I was researching this episode who said, when someone tells me I'm being too sensitive, I always come back to them and say, well, maybe you're being too insensitive. Just because my way of seeing the world is more rare doesn't make it worse and it doesn't make it the one that needs fixing. So that rant aside, let's talk about some tips about how to make an insensitive world more suitable for your beautiful sensitive soul. first off the bat, if you want to get more comfortable with being a highly sensitive person, you really need to honour your sensitivity by learning what in your life makes things easier for you and lighter for you and what makes things feel harder. Highly sensitive people just need more time than others to process the things that happen in their day, in their environment, in their
我在研究这一集时从一个非常棒的人那里听到这样的话：当有人告诉我我太敏感时，我总是反驳他们说，嗯，也许是你太不敏感了。仅仅因为我看到世界的方式更为罕见，并不意味着它更糟糕，也不意味着它是那个需要被修复的一方。所以，抛开这些长篇大论，让我们来谈谈一些小建议，看看如何让一个不敏感的世界更适合你美丽敏感的灵魂。首先，如果你想对成为一个高度敏感的人感到更自在，你真的需要通过了解你生活中什么能让事情对你而言更轻松、更轻盈，什么会让事情感觉更艰难，来尊重你的敏感。高度敏感的人只是需要比其他人更多的时间来处理他们的一天、他们的环境、他们的
relationships. So give yourself that time rather than trying to overload yourself. to fit in. Notice your limits and put yourself in environments that aren't going to make things more difficult for you. So for example, if you've got a big call with your boss tomorrow morning, don't schedule an intense catch up with an old friend in the same day. Space things out. Give yourself time to return to that normal, steady, stable state before you throw yourself into the next situation. I think adjusting to being a highly sensitive person or just adjusting to being a highly sensitive person or just adjusting to your acknowledgement and your respect of your identity as a highly sensitive person means appreciating and finally accepting that
人际关系中发生的事情。所以，与其试图让自己超载去迎合别人，不如给自己这段时间。注意你的极限，把自己放在不会让事情变得对你而言更加困难的环境中。所以，例如，如果你明天早上有一个与老板的重要通话，就不要在同一天安排与老朋友的高强度聚会。把事情错开。在让自己投入到下一个情境之前，给自己时间回到那种正常、平稳、稳定的状态。我认为适应作为一个高度敏感的人，或者仅仅是适应你对作为一个高度敏感的人的身份的认可和尊重，意味着去欣赏并最终接受
maybe you can't do everything the way that everyone else does it. It doesn't mean that you can't do it though. It just means that you have to find a way for it to work with you. Otherwise, it's just going to be really, you know, unenjoyable. My second piece of advice is to practice the kind of self-care that works for you because it's probably going to look different from the self-care that 80% of the world likes to do. You know, for some people, self-care is socializing. It's treating themselves, going shopping, letting loose.
也许你无法像其他人那样做所有事情。但这并不意味着你做不到。这只是意味着你必须找到一种适合你的方式来完成它。否则，那真的会变得（你知道的）非常令人不快。我的第二个建议是练习适合你的那类自我照顾，因为它看起来可能与世界上80%的人喜欢做的自我照顾大不相同。你知道的，对某些人来说，自我照顾是社交。是犒劳自己、去购物、释放自我。
For you, it's probably going to involve slowing down. Resting and saying no. You know, no, sorry, I don't want to go to dinner at that crowded restaurant. No, I don't want your friend. I don't like to join us for dinner. Sorry, I don't want to have this conversation right now. self-care is as much about adding things to your life as it is about saying no and subtracting things in your life to give yourself adequate downtime to emotionally regulate to give yourself time to rest
对你来说，它可能需要放慢脚步。休息和说“不”。你知道的，“不，对不起，我不想去那家拥挤的餐厅吃晚饭。”“不，我不想要你的朋友……我不想让他加入我们的晚餐。”“对不起，我现在不想谈这个。”自我照顾既包括为生活增添事物，也包括说“不”并减去生活中的事物，从而给自己留出足够的停机时间来调节情绪，给自己时间休息
and to think you know what else is like a profoundly sweet simple but overlooked form of self-care just giving yourself more time to get places giving yourself more time to organize your day finish up your work, you know, just five minutes earlier. Even if you feel drawn to keep working, you know that you'll need that five minutes to separate your real life from your work life and to really get back into a stable, steady state. Give yourself the extra 10, 15 minutes to get somewhere, even if it means getting there early because you don't want to be flustered. You don't want to be hot, sticky, overwhelmed. You don't want to hate the texture of your outfit, you know, right when you were meant to be leaving and then feel rushed. to change, give yourself a bit more time.
和思考。你知道还有什么是一种深刻甜蜜、简单却被忽视的自我照顾形式吗？就是给自己更多的时间去目的地；给自己更多的时间来整理一天的行程、完成工作，（你知道的）哪怕提前五分钟也好。即使你觉得自己被吸引着想继续工作，你也知道你需要那五分钟来把现实生活与工作生活隔离开来，并真正回到稳定、平稳的状态。给自己额外的10、15分钟去某个地方，即使这意味着早到，因为你不想慌乱。你不想又热、又黏、又不知所措。你不想（就在你本该离开的时候）讨厌你衣服的质感，然后感到仓促
I think the crucial rule when it comes to self-care, the golden rule, is make smart choices that will help your future self based on what has hurt or overwhelmed your past self. I had a friend tell me about a technique she uses that is kind of similar to that idea. And it's called, what she does is she creates relaxing zones in her house and even at her job. And having been to her home, it is like walking into her home. it is like walking into the most comfortable and homely therapist office that you've ever been in. She's not even a therapist. It's just so calming.
去换衣服，多给自己一点时间。我认为在自我照顾方面至关重要的规则，即黄金规则，就是：根据过去伤害过你或让你不知所措的经历，做出明智的选择，以帮助未来的自己。我有一个朋友跟我讲过一个她使用的技巧，有点类似于这个想法。那就是——她做的是在家里甚至是工作场所创造放松区。去过她家之后，那感觉就像走进她家一样。
It always smells like lemon and honey. There are never any like really big overhead lights on. She has cozy surfaces everywhere you look. She has beautiful things. And walking into that environment, it's just like so obvious that she has intentionally made this a safe space for herself and that she has gone out of her way. she's put in the effort before to, you know, provide this gift to every future version of her who needs to walk into her home after a big, long day where she's been absorbing everyone else's emotions and everything around her and she just wants to calm down and she has given that to herself.
那里总是弥漫着柠檬和蜂蜜的香气。从没有开那些真的很刺眼的顶灯。你目光所及之处都有舒适的表面。她有美好的事物。走进那样的环境，很明显她是有意为自己营造了一个安全空间，并且她付出了额外的努力。她之前付出了努力，（你知道的）把这份礼物提供给未来的每一个自己——当她在漫长而疲惫的一天后，吸收了所有其他人的情绪以及周围的一切，只想平静下来时，她把这给了自己。
And the reason why I really like that she's done this is because when you walk into her house, you just feel like your body, your mind, your soul, whatever it is, is being cleansed. And as a highly sensitive person, it's kind of like walking outside in really, really sticky shoes. And like you pick up so many things. You pick up the gum. You pick up the cigarette butts. You pick up the pigeon poop. And you take it all home with you.
我真的很喜欢她这么做，原因在于当你走进她的房子时，你只会觉得你的身体、你的心灵、你的灵魂，无论是什么，都被净化了。作为一个高度敏感的人，那感觉就像穿着黏糊糊的鞋子走在外面。你会沾上很多东西。你会粘上口香糖。你会粘上烟头。你会粘上鸽子粪。然后你把这一切都带回家。
And, you know, you pick up the emotions. You pick up the sensory overload. You pick up the exhausting conversation someone was having on the train and the loud lights and whatever it is. And you take that all home with you. And when you get home, you need to clean out the filter. You need to clean off the shoes. Because you are not like everyone else. you are a collector of information.
而且，（你知道的）你吸收了情绪。你吸收了感官过载。你吸收了某人在火车上进行的让人筋疲力尽的谈话、刺眼的灯光以及诸如此类的一切。然后你把这些全带回家。当你回到家时，你需要清理过滤器。你需要把鞋子上的脏东西清理掉。因为你和大家不一样。你是一个信息的收集者。
Like that's what your brain has developed to do based on your genetics, based on your childhood, based on whatever has contributed to your high sensitivity. All of that has just made everything much louder for you. So you need a space that allows you to turn it down and to kind of clean off the junk and clean out the junk from your brain. As a highly sensitive person, I also think it's worth being selective about the people you choose to be around.
就像这是你的大脑根据你的基因、童年以及任何促成你高敏感性的因素而发育出的功能一样。所有这一切只是让对你而言的一切都变得更加喧闹。所以你需要一个空间，让你能够把音量调小，并清理掉大脑中的垃圾。作为一个高敏感的人，我也认为对于你选择交往的人，值得有所选择。
You are like a sponge. You are perpetually in a state of osmosis with the people around you. You absorb their emotions, their reactions, their fears, their joy. If the people around you, your friends, are super reactive or really unpredictable, dramatic, always really high, high, high or extremely low, guess how you're going to be feeling? The exact same way. I see so many people try really hard to be friends with people they are just,
你就像一块海绵。你与周围的人永久处于渗透状态中。你吸收他们的情绪、他们的反应、他们的恐惧、他们的喜悦。如果你周围的人、你的朋友反应极其激烈，或者非常不可预测、戏剧化、情绪总是处于极高或极低的极端，猜猜你会有什么感觉？完全一样。我看到很多人非常努力地想和那些他们根本不该、
you know, just simply shouldn't be friends with. Not because those people are toxic or awful, any of those labels. They just shouldn't be friends because their emotional energies don't align. And it ends up going sour because everything they feel, you feel. And so it becomes hard not to take things personally or to leave every hangout feeling super drained and like you just don't want to see them again. Or feeling really on edge and snapping or saying something you don't mean. Now, this piece of advice isn't to say drop all your friends. start from scratch, but really assess who do I leave interactions with, feeling calm, serene, and
你知道，其实就不应该和他们做朋友。并不是因为这些人有毒或糟糕，或者被贴上任何这类标签。他们只是不适合做朋友，因为他们的情感能量并不契合。最后结果往往会变糟，因为他们感受到的每一种情绪，你也能感受到。因此，你很难不把事情往心里去，也很难在每次聚会后不感到精疲力竭，甚至觉得再也不想见他们了。或者感到非常紧张、易怒，说出并非本意的话。现在，这条建议并不是说让你抛弃所有的朋友，从头开始，而是要真正评估一下：我和谁互动后离开时会感到平静、安详，并且
seen, who do I leave interactions with, feeling on edge, exhausted, highly strong? Maybe those people become a once-in-a-while friend, rather than an everyday friend. On that note, I want to say one final boundary. Anyone again who says you are too emotional, who says that you take things too personally, that you need to calm down, those people should be never friends. They don't deserve you. And it's too bad for them because they don't get to be touched by your gentleness and your extreme appreciation for beauty and empathy and kindness. They don't get the gift of this aspect of you. but I honestly think that it is their loss because if they're not willing to accept every single part of you including the part of you that honestly I think is so unique and beautiful they're just
从零开始，而是要真正评估：我和谁互动后会感到平静、宁静和被看见？我和谁互动后会感到如坐针毡、筋疲力竭、高度紧张？也许这些人应该成为偶尔联系的朋友，而不是每天都见的朋友。顺便说一句，我想划定最后一条界限。任何再说你太情绪化、说你太把事情往心里去、说你需要冷静下来的人，都绝不应该成为朋友。他们不配拥有你。这对他们来说太遗憾了，因为他们无法被你的温柔、你对美、同理心和善良的极致欣赏所触及。他们得不到你身上这部分特质所赋予的礼物。但我真心觉得这是他们的损失，因为如果他们不愿意接受你的每一个部分——包括我真心认为既独特又美丽的那个部分——他们就
not it they don't deserve to be in your life and you know that you will end up picking up on how they're feeling about you and it's just going to always keep you in a heightened state if someone says you know you're just so sensitive it's also worthwhile just saying back to them like you know I know it's great I love it I love that I get to feel so much much. Stop trying, like, you know, they're not allowed to make you feel bad. If they say you're overreacting, literally just be like, um, so what would an appropriate reaction be? Or I just don't think that you're seeing the situation in the same way. I think you're underreacting. You're, you're allowed to assert yourself just because your sensitivity has been labeled as weakness. It's not,
根本不行。他们不配进入你的生活，而且你知道你最终会觉察到他们对你的看法，这只会让你一直处于高度紧张的状态。如果有人说（你知道的）“你就是太敏感了”，那么回敬他们一句也是很有价值的，比如：“你知道吗，这很棒，我很喜欢。我喜欢我能感受到这么多东西。”别再试图……（你知道的），他们没权力让你感觉糟糕。如果他们说你反应过度，直截了当回击：“嗯，那什么样的反应才算适当呢？”或者“我只是觉得你看待问题的方式不对。我觉得你反应不足。”你可以坚持自我。仅仅因为你的敏感被贴上了软弱的标签，它就不是软弱，
firstly. But you're allowed to disagree. You're allowed to say, actually no, I really like this part of me. I actually really like who it makes me. I like that I notice things. I like that I love the world. So I'm going to keep it that way. Thank you for your opinion. Moving on. I really do hope that this episode has helped you in some way. I hope that it's normalized an emotional experience that you're having or a perspective. I hope that you feel seen. I hope that you feel heard. I hope that you feel held and that you feel loved because I really do love highly sensitive people. They're my favorites. You are my favourite. I just think that they make the world so special.
首先，你完全有权不同意。你完全可以说：“其实不，我真的很喜欢我身上的这一部分。我其实真的很喜欢它塑造的我。我喜欢我能注意到事物。我喜欢我热爱这个世界。所以我要保持这样。谢谢你的意见。下一个。”我真的希望这一集在某种程度上对你有所帮助。我希望它让你正在经历的情绪体验或某种视角变得正常化。我希望你觉得自己被看见了。我希望你觉得自己被听见了。我希望你觉得自己被拥抱、被爱，因为我确实非常喜欢高度敏感的人。他们是我最喜欢的。你是我的最爱。我只是觉得他们让这个世界变得如此特别。
Without them, the world would be so cruel and so ugly. So thank you for doing us all the service by existing. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, send it to a friend. I'm sure that they would love to hear it. Send it to someone who maybe just doesn't get your sensitive brain so that they can learn a little bit more. I'm sure they would appreciate being able to be on your level. Make sure that you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
如果没有他们，世界将会变得多么残酷和丑陋。所以谢谢你们通过存在为我们大家做出的贡献。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请把它发给朋友。我确信他们会很乐意听的。把它发给那些可能只是无法理解你那敏感大脑的人，这样他们就能多了解一点。我确信他们会感激能够与你在同一频段上。请务必在Apple Podcasts、Spotify、
wherever you are listening right now and that you are following along for more episodes coming out soon. Also, if you have an episode suggestion, if you're a highly sensitive person and you want to tell me a little bit more about your experience, maybe for a follow-up episode, for something that I might post on Instagram,
或者你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，并关注以获取即将发布的更多剧集。另外，如果你有什么剧集建议，如果你是一个高度敏感的人，想告诉我更多关于你的经历，可能是为了后续的节目，或者是为了我可能会发布在Instagram上的内容，
please DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I would love to hear from you, and until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle to yourself. Be gentle to your sensitive little soul. You deserve it, and we will talk. soon.
请在Instagram上私信我：That Psychology Podcast。我很期待听到你们的声音。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。对你敏感的小灵魂温柔一点。你配得上这一切，我们很快再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧精神、体能和抗逆力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
收听《2%》。也就是IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Percent”。在《回顾过去》播客中。1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的朋友以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，大家好，你们正在收听《迎难而上》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着西装或铠甲？它向世界发出的信号是：你是不容招惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。收听并在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《迎难而上》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克特被指控生下了一对双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini.
但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦斯女士，你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮，迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听《爱情陷阱》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。